America's caffeine addiction has deep
roots in 1912 the chief chemist for the
USDA warned this country is full of tea
and coffee drunkards the US government
even sued coca-cola for adding caffeine
to the drink prohibition banned the
production and sale of alcohol in 1920
it was a win for the temperance movement
it was also a win for bootleggers
speakeasies and gangsters who cashed in
on black-market booze by 1927 there were
twice as many speakeasies in New York as
pre-prohibition bars marijuana and
heroin were all the rage in the Bohemian
jazz scene of the 1930s the government
created the Federal Bureau of Narcotics
to crack down on illegal drugs and
marijuana was officially outlawed in
1937 and reefer madness stoked fears of
the evil weed doctors started
prescribing and feta means two soldiers
returning from World War two to fight
combat fatigue while students and
athletes were popping them to increase
performance World War two pilots even
received Benzedrine in their flight kits
the age of advertising takes off and
adds four Milltown and other sedatives
appeal directly to the public mother's
little helper pills were prescribed as a
quick fix for anxiety one in 20
Americans were using it drugs went
mainstream as the era of free love led
to young white middle-class Americans
loosening up with help from marijuana
it's considered the beginning of the
modern drug epidemic
harder drugs like cocaine and heroin
became more common at the stigma on drug
use eased up to 15% of troops in Vietnam
used heroin but President Nixon was
going to war America's public enemy
number one in the United States is drug
abuse cocaine got more popular and crack
cocaine appeared on the scene as did
tough laws that disproportionately
targeted minorities crack was cheaper
than cocaine but sentences for
possession were a hundred times harsher
President Reagan launched the just say
no campaign say no to drugs and say yes
to life club drugs like ecstasy fueled
the party scene MDMA let crowds party
all night and stoked feelings of
connection and euphoria in 1997 one in
sixteen students entering high school
had tried ecstasy popping prescription
painkillers like oxycodone became easier
because of lacks prescription tracking
laws especially in Florida 90 of the top
100 prescribing doctors were operating
in the state the pills made their way
north via the oxy express with states
cracking down on prescription pills
people turn to heroin for a cheaper and
easier high and a new heroin epidemic
quietly takes root heroin use has more
than doubled in the past decade
HSBC knowingly turned a blind eye to the
Sinaloa cartel that was laundering money
through its banks and yet it did
purposefully widen some of